hey guys this is inka and today i'm
going to be trying to make
the super fluffy cloud bread using only
three ingredients
and none of them will be flower products
so recently i feel like this cloud bread
has been blowing up on the internet
specifically on tick tock
it's like everywhere on my for you page
it's basically this really poofy
and extremely fluffy almost meringue
like cake that ends up looking like a
cloud because of how light it is
what's really interesting is that the
original cloud bread has actually been
around for quite a while i think the
last one that blew up was a keto
friendly version the way you would make
it was using some cream of tartar some
eggs
and some greek yogurt or cream cheese
but this version is a little more
indulgent and
also a lot fluffier so i think you guys
will like it a lot
it also looks super simple and super
straightforward so i am very excited to
test it out let's get started so for
ingredients
all you need are three egg whites which
we will separate later 30 grams of sugar
which is around two and a half
tablespoons
10 grams of corn starch which averages
out to around
a little over a tablespoon that's about
it this is all you need to make that
crazy fluffy bread you've probably been
seeing everywhere for fun though you
can add some food coloring so i also
grabbed my blue magic powder because it
is this beautifully vibrant shade of
blue to make it a little more colorful
now i'm just going to go preheat my oven
to 350 degrees fahrenheit and you guys
can follow along if you want to this
could just be a really fun little
project first thing we're going to do is
just to separate our egg whites from our
egg yolks what i like doing is just
cracking them all open and then scooping
the egg yolks out
like the cleanest way to do it and don't
throw your eggs away because you can do
so much with this you can make carbonara
or just cure them
for now we're just going to set that
aside got my egg whites in here i am
going to go ahead and put them in a
bigger mixing bowl
and grab your whisk because here we go
again
it is our muscle time we are going to
whip these egg whites and gradually add
our sugar
in and i am getting dagona coffee
flashbacks
nine minutes in and i am sweating
but since this is the way i saw them do
it in the viral tick tocks
this is what i'm gonna use i'm gonna
start timing this
once i see it start foaming up a little
bit i'm gonna add a sprinkle of sugar
i told myself i wouldn't do this again
but here i am
oh my god my arms
more sugar
okay we're getting super soft peaks we
need
stiff peaks so we have still quite a way
to go
it is looking pretty good this is a good
time to add in the cornstarch
it's almost almost almost almost almost
you guys that is a stiff peak
and it is not going to fall that's when
you know you've done it right
and this is around how long i've gone
for it's like 10
minutes and 30 seconds
very straightforward but definitely time
consuming if you
do not have fun gadgets to help you so
what i have to do now
is well first to rest your arms if you
needed i also have
a baking sheet prepped here with some
parchment paper
and we're just going to shape this on
our tray
into a perfect mound of
fluffiness but also remember how i said
i wanted to test out the blue
so i am going to actually half this and
mix some of this
with the blue magic powder mix it up you
see how that turns it into
a very very light shade of blue i feel
like i'm painting a little bit wow it's
really pretty though
here's what i have i am going to plop
this on
my baking tray just gonna do a little
bit of like alternating
it doesn't have to be perfect yet look
at this blue and white though
it looks a little bit like clouds right
hopefully it's going to
turn out like that now i have all of it
on my baking sheet i am just going to
shape it
so that it has that beautifully smoothed
out top
all right you guys here's what i have
look at this blue and white mount
this is my cloud bread i really tried to
make it look
as close to a cloud painting as possible
i hope i didn't take too much time but
it literally weighs
nothing so i'm gonna pop this in the
oven now and wait for around 20 minutes
and then i can show you guys what the
final product looks like i am
excited cloud bread going in see you
soon
it's done okay hold on oh my god look at
it look at this poofy little thing
there's literally like this
little pillow of fluffiness i know this
deflates
if we let it sit too long so i am going
to very quickly
try to scoop it out but i am very
excited it has definitely kept its shape
oh my god you guys
carefully threw it off yeah it's hot
but we gotta do this ready we're going
to just open this
and oh my goodness you guys
look at this it is
truly magnificent wow
spongy texture these kind of look like
clouds right it
is so light and fluffy and it smells
it smells very eggy wow i mean
look at it it's like so light i love how
it ended up being this like super light
blue and white
it's like fluffy clouds on a blue sky
it's so pretty
i'm just going to take a bite while it's
still hot
it's so interesting because when you eat
it it's actually not that sweet i know
when i'm pressing down on it the texture
feels like it would be almost like a
marshmallow but when you eat it
even though i feel like this is very
heavily meringue based it's not so much
of a melt-in-your-mouth sort of texture
and i think the exterior is actually a
little bit chillier but the inside
is super soft i really think the closest
thing to this would be like
a sponge cake isn't that so crazy that
there's like no
flour in this i'm genuinely so surprised
to be able to get this much volume and
this sort of texture
knowing that you only have three
ingredients is pretty
pretty cool i also think there's so much
more you can do with this bread in terms
of like patterns and flavors like you
can make a matcha flavored one
if you get the whisking part down this
is truly
one of those things that i think is
worth a try so i would give it pretty
high points for both flavor and texture
that's it this is the super fluffy cloud
bread
i think you guys can have so much fun
with this so give it a try
and i will see you guys next time for
when i try out the next viral recipe
cheers
you